For this equation, the center is at O,O the a value is 10 since we moved 10
units in the x direction, left and right. And the b value is 5 since we moved
vertically from the center 5 units up and 5 units down. Now if you're stumped
about what to do first, remember that we want this to equal one, so we should
divide our equation through by 400. So, we'll take our equation and divide each
term by 400 4 divides into 4, leaving us with 1X squared in the numerator. And
4 divides into 400, leaving 100 in the denominator. For the second term, 16
divides into 16 one time, and 16 divides into 400 25 times. So, we'll have 1Y
squared, divided by 25. And finally, on the other side of the equals sign,
we'll have one, since 400 divided by 400 equals one. Now we're looking at an
equation that fits our general form when the ellipse is centered at the origin.
The center is 0, 0, since there's nothing next to the x and nothing next to the
y. We simply just have x squared and y squared. Now, the a value is the square
root of this number. So, the a value must be 10. And the b value is the square
root of this number. So b must be positive 5. If it helps you, you can rewrite
the denominators as perfect squares. This easily let's you find the a value and
the b value. So, we took this equation, and we changed it to look like
something else. We've changed the equation to look like this. Let's graph this
one to make sure they're identical. So, so far we have our old blue ellipse
just like from before that represents this first equation. And you can see that
I'm on it since it's become bold, since I've clicked on it. Now if I take our
equation and I set it equal to 1, we have the same exact ellipse. We moved 10
units in the x direction, left and right, and 5 units in the vertical
direction, up and down. And we can even write the equation in this form with
100 as 10 squared and 25 as 5 squared. And if I set this equal to 1, I get the
exact same elipse. These three equations are written in different forms, but
they're all equivalent.